let's talk about tick tock and the u.s
presidential election
the app has a lot of people talking and
dancing lip syncing
and lately even campaigning please go
vote when november come around so we can
get him out of here
owned by a company in china tick tock
has 800 million
users worldwide and it's growing fast
but there are those who see it as a
threat we may be banning tick tock
we are looking at a lot of alternatives
so why is tick tock getting all this
attention
is our privacy at risk and does this app
like other social media platforms
have the potential to influence the us
election
[Music]
let's be clear facebook is still the
biggest and most valuable social media
company in the world
but there's a new kid on the block tick
tock's been around for only three years
and it's blowing up especially in
america carol basket
killed her husband
[Music]
tick tock makes it easy to upload videos
add effects
choose music switch up recording speeds
you can even change what you look like
but it's even easier to just get
lost in it this app is essentially an
endless scroll of
punchy videos that are a maximum 60
seconds long
it's also got its own tick tock
celebrities
a chinese company called bite dance
launched tiktok in 2017
real videos that make your day it later
bought the popular silicon valley
startup
musically for a billion dollars and
merged the two
today tick tock is worth more than 75
billion
it's got an american ceo but it's still
chinese-owned
in the u.s especially it's experienced
such a rapid growth last statistics i
saw was that
the year-on-year growth was 375 percent
which is huge here's how huge in the
first
three months of the year tick tock was
downloaded more than 300 million times
globally
that's a record but in terms of overall
monthly active users
it's still behind facebook's more than 2
billion but
way ahead of twitter and snapchat and a
lot of tick tock's users are young
around 40 percent are between 16 and 24.
ahead of a presidential election that's
millions of potential new votes
and what was once seen as just a fun app
is
actually getting more political i'm a
vote trump 2020 trump 2020.
it's really a platform that allows for a
very wide array
of political expression so yes there's
the activist
content but there's also a lot of
conservative political content
and it's gone beyond just posting
political views
in the last year tick tock has
demonstrated its power to mobilize
hashtags help they make tick-tock
content searchable
and easier to go viral that's what
happened in may during the protests over
the killing of george floyd by police
tick talkers have also been credited
with using the app to pull off some
pretty big pranks just before a trump
rally in tulsa oklahoma
thousands of korean pop music fans had
the idea of reserving free tickets
without showing up
and the message went viral on tech talk
i recommend
all of those of us that want to see this
19 000 seat auditorium barely filled or
completely empty
go reserve tickets now and leave him
standing there alone on the stage what
do you say
it definitely looked like they pulled it
off
the trump campaign said tick-tockers and
k-pop fans weren't the reason
though they did acknowledge thousands of
fake phone numbers were registered
generation z etc are wielding social
media and mobilizing it and i think part
of it is just they have been on social
media pretty much their entire lives
some argue that these types of political
movements are able to snowball because
tick tock
feeds you what you want to see and hear
the algorithm collects mountains of data
on videos you like
and users you follow and it uses that
data to create tick tock's homepage
that's called
for you it's a hyper personalized loop
of videos
it thinks you might like you as a
company
you want a user to spend as much time on
your platform
as possible and the way you do that is
you create an experience
that is enhanced by your own likes but
once a social media platform gets this
popular
people notice its power starting with
that echo chamber and its potential to
perpetuate
hateful or inaccurate content the
prejudices the
sort of uh perpetuation of conspiracy
theories
the online space the way to amplify it
and that's not just a problem for tick
tock
that was the very criticism leveled
against facebook in 2016
during the last presidential election
the big scandal for tick tock so far
though
has been about security last year
checkpoint research said it had found
ways
hackers could tamper with tick-tock
accounts by for example
making private content public the u.s
military has even ordered its personnel
to delete the app
it is not just the trump campaign or the
trump white house that is making this
claim other companies have asked their
employees to do similar things
tick tock says it's fixed the security
issues but it's got other problems
u.s officials have been investigating
tick tock because even though it's an
american operation
it's owned by a chinese company and
chinese companies by law
can be forced to hand over personal data
to the government
now tik tok denies all of this and
insists the data
is private secure and stored on servers
in the us
but the trump administration is now
considering a ban
the trump campaign even took out
facebook ads to get supporters to sign a
petition
would you recommend that people download
that up on their phones
tonight tomorrow anytime currently
only if you want your private
information in the hands of the chinese
communist party
now it's unclear if the u.s can actually
ban the app
or if there's truth to reports that a
u.s company is trying to buy tick-tock
which would sever chinese control
but the prospect of a ban was enough to
get its users riled up
now i don't think it's a coincidence
after tulsa was a flop
out of the blue now suddenly you want to
go ahead and band-aid [ __ ] a bunch of
tick-tockers
flooded the trump campaign's mobile app
with bad reviews
if an app gets underneath one star apple
will actually delete
the app so let's delete that thing so
aside from all the pranks the hype and
the concerns
tick tock's expected to be a real player
in this election because while older
americans in swing states won
trump the presidency in 2016 this year
there are many more young voters
a third of the electorate are
millennials and some studies suggest
they tend to skew democrat that's a lot
of votes
if they show up that is we know
traditionally that youth voters
haven't turned out in numbers that we
like but we also know that this
generation of people is very politically
and socially active
some think it could be an important tool
to mobilize voters
but there's no question that when it
comes to this presidential race
facebook is still the real battleground
it's simply a bigger platform with more
users
and that means it has access to more
personal information
the company makes money from all that
data which we give up for free
and facebook sells it to advertisers who
tailor those ads to each of us
it's called micro targeting the issue
with facebook is keeping that data
secure so it's not misused
that's what happened the last time
around in 2018
it was revealed that the now defunct
political consulting firm cambridge
analytica
has stolen the data of millions of
facebook users
that data was used to create
psychological profiles
target u.s swing voters and then attempt
to manipulate them
for the then presidential candidate
donald trump during the 2016 election
it got the head of facebook in hot water
at the time
we didn't take a broad enough view of
our responsibility
and that was a big mistake facebook now
says it's got better safeguards for our
data
and it's changing its settings so that
users can see fewer political ads
we just have to manually opt out it also
says it's cracking down on foreign
interference
facebook has in recent months taken down
a very high number of networks and
operations
they're led by different states from
iran
to russia as for tick tock it's also
facing allegations of foreign
interference
something both tiktok and the chinese
government deny
women
so what about misinformation content
that's just plain wrong
ahead of the elections the pressure is
piling on social media companies to do
more
to step in and take down fake or
misleading posts
facebook's facing most of the heat tick
tock is feeling it too
the company says it's launching what it
calls a transparency center in
california to moderate content
it's blocked a bunch of hashtags linked
to the q anon conspiracy movement
and it's also been taking down
inaccurate videos
like this one of joe biden appearing to
endorse trump
we can only re-elect donald trump the
president even tweeted it
but here's what biden actually said
excuse me we can only
re-elect donald trump if in fact we get
engaged in this circular firing squad
here
so we know that tick-tock is already
starting to experience some of the
problems that older social networks are
and the more tick tock grows and the
closer we get to november
the more the company finds itself in the
middle of a debate over
how much social platforms should police
content
i think it's generally difficult for
facebook and for other
social media platforms to strike the
right chord on the one hand they have
this
imperative to curb the spread of
misinformation on the platform
and that entails removing problematic
content
but when they do that they're accused of
censorship
and if they do nothing then they're also
criticized for inaction
this election is going to play out on
all the social platforms
it's just that right now tick tock's got
momentum
it's why anyone in politics is paying
attention
[Music]
we'll have a lot more on the u.s
presidential election in the run-up to
the november vote
so if you don't want to miss those
episodes you can like follow and
subscribe to al jazeera wherever you're
watching this video
i'll see you next week